>>Female Presenter: How many of you guys are
familiar with Rick's work?
Awesome.
Well, the thing about Rick is his
work is amazing, but he is the best teacher
and he makes
things so accessible.
He's such an inspiration and he's
such a giver, and the more you get to know
him, you
realize he's not -- he's one of those people
that
doesn't allow fears to hold him back, and
he's just
awesome person.
And, and he makes beautiful, beautiful,
beautiful photos no matter what the conditions.
So
without further ado.
>>RICK: Okay.
Thank you, world-famous Katherine Hall.
[Clapping]
>>RICK: Thank you so much, Katherine, and
thank
you all for coming.
This is the second time I've spoken
at Google.
It is an honor, it's a pleasure to speak
here and it's very exciting.
I know this is broadcast
all around the world and it's going to be
be archived so
it'll be on YouTube so this is really, really
exciting.
And right after this, I'm getting my Google+
T-shirt.
I
couldn't get to the gift shop before, so right
after I'm
definitely getting my Google+ T-shirt.
This talk is
going to be about travel photography.
Now, I like to
make my talks interactive so please ask questions
during
the talk.
If it requires a long answer, well, I'll
answer it afterward.
If it's a short -- you know, like
we were talking about polarizing filters before.
What
does a polarizing filter do?
I'll answer it during the
session.
But please, you know, ask questions, make
it
interactive.
It makes it more fun for me and makes it
more fun for you.
And Cliff, do you want to say a few
words before we get going?
>>CLIFF: Oh, sure.
>>RICK: Come on in.
The world-famous Cliff,
who arranged this whole thing.
>> CLIFF: All right.
Okay.
>>RICK: Oh.
He's getting out his notes.
Rick
Sammon is the Canon explorer of light.
>>CLIFF: Yeah, I'm really mean now.
>> RICK: Okay.
Here we go.
>> CLIFF: I'll have to speak in the mic.
I
mean, we really -- Rick as you already started
talking
we just really want to welcome you back to
Google.
It's
always great to have a return visit.
And as you all
probably know Rick is very active on Google+,
too.
So
it's really becoming the nexus for photography
online
and we're really grateful for your -- for
your use of
the product, and for your sharing these great
images.
And he is an explorer of light.
And with that, go ahead
and continue.
>> RICK: Okay.
And actually one more person
wants to introduce me -- no.
I'm only kidding.
So this
presentation is about travel photography.
I'm basically a travel
photographer.
The difference between the travel
photographer and the photojournalist -- we
were talking
about photojournalism before -- a photojournalist
goes
out and usually shoots just what's there;
I spend a lot of
time making pictures.
There's a big difference between
taking a picture and making the picture although
I do
have some photojournalistic-type pictures
in here.
So
I'm going to start out -- everyone wants to
be a travel
photographer.
Oh, man, I would love to travel the
world.
I've been to more than a hundred countries.
People say I would love to be a travel photographer.
Well, I'm going to start out with a travel
story, and
you might want to reconsider how great it
is being a
travel photographer.
[chuckles] This is one of my favorite
pictures from Antarctica.
I've been to Antarctica
twice.
This looks just like a polar bear.
This is
amazing, right?
You can see the eyes, the ears, the
mouth, the paws, it's on its back with its
knee and its
foot up in the air.
Well, this is my favorite picture.
I took this picture on my first trip to Antarctica
about
four years ago.
And the thing about my work is.
I lead
a lot of workshops around the world.
I leave a lot
of -- lead a lot of travel photography workshops.
So
the deal is, I get a free trip in exchange
for teaching
the people how to take pictures.
It's kind of cool.
But listen to this: There's no such thing
as a free
lunch because, [chuckling] you know, people
knock on your door at
9:00 o'clock oh, can you help me clean my
sensor?
I
can't find out what custom function 42 does,
and things
like that.
So it is a lot of work.
It's a lot of fun,
but it's a lot of work.
Also, it doesn't really matter
what type of camera you have.
I shoot with digital SLR,
some people shoot with smartphone cameras
-- I think the
mic just went out -- but it doesn't really
matter for
this talk because the tips I give really apply
to all
different types of photography.
So let me tell you
about my first trip to Antarctica.
It was amazing.
You
fly from New York to Buenos Aires, and then
down to
Ushuaia, which is the southernmost-most city
on the
planet.
From there, you go across the Drake's Passage.
Three days.
You're on the ship for three days over what
can be the roughest seas in the world.
They can have
60-foot seas here; this time we were lucky,
but you can
get seasick.
They can give you a shot to put you out if
you want to be out for three days.
But are there any
people of a medical background here?
Because there are
two stages, clinical stages of being seasick.
The first
stage is you feel like you're going to die;
the second
stage is you wish you were dead.
[Laughing]
>> RICK: And this is true, because I have
been
seasick on some of these cruises.
But I went to
Antarctica to photograph -- to photograph
all the
beautiful animals, the penguins, you know,
the seals,
all this stuff, but I fell in love -- I fell
in love
with the blue ice.
The blue ice down there is
incredible.
Here, I'm using a 15-millimeter fish eye
lens on my Canon 5D Mark II, which is a full
frame image
sensor camera.
And again, if you guys have any
questions about like where were we just standing,
I was
actually wearing my Wellington boots standing
in the
ice.
I was moving around.
If you have any questions
like that during the presentation, please
ask.
But you
know I was at the bottom of the world and
I thought
maybe a 15-millimeter full frame fish eye
lens would
help tell the story about being at the bottom
of the
world.
I'm also going to throw in some technical
tips
here.
You see that everything in this scene here
is in focus from the
ship in the back to the foreground here.
To get
everything into scene and focus, what you
want to do is
use a wide angle lens, set a small aperture,
and focus
1/3 into the scene.
Now that may sound backwards.
You
might think oh, that's so far away.
I want to focus 2/3
into the scene.
You focus 1/3 into the scene.
That'll
give you the -- a maximum amount of the scene
in focus.
You're really setting the lens up for what's
called the
hyperfocal point.
But I fell in love with this
beautiful blue ice.
Just look at these formations.
Now, I'm riding around in a zodiac, which
is an
inflatable boat.
They don't let you get too close to
these because these things can flip over like
a moment's
notice.
It's very exciting to be down there at the
bottom of the world.
But look at this ice castle here.
This ice castle is amazing.
So we spent a lot of time
riding around in these zodiacs.
Before we got going we
were talking about a polarizing filter.
The only filter
that I use outside is a polarizing filter.
Polarizing
filter reduces glare on water, glare on ice,
glare on
windows, glare on leaves, but it could also
make your
pictures look sharper because it cuts down
on the
reflections of the moisture in the atmospheric
haze.
It's the only filter I use outside.
I used to use
gradual filters that are half dark on top
and gradually
go clear on the bottom unless you hold them
upside down [chuckles lightly]
and it's the opposite way, but that's the
only filter I
use for my travel photography.
If I'm doing a
waterfall, I'll use a neutral density filter.
When
there's not a lot of color in the scene, like
you see
here, what I like to do is I like to make
my pictures a
black and white; I like to make a monochromatic
image.
Here's another example of this beautiful ice
formation.
Now, you notice the pictures are a little
stretched here
on this monitor.
If I go back quickly to the first
picture, you'll see that this is cropped actually
kind
of like the for -- come on in we have first
class seats
and business class seats right over here [chuckles]--
cropped in
the HD format or the panorama format.
The first
thing that I do -- I don't know about Katherine,
but the
first thing that I do is I crop my pictures.
I try to
get the shot, you know, perfect in camera,
but I lot of
times you can't.
I like to crop out, like look at this
picture.
I'm on my monitor here it's cropped -- if
I go
back -- on my monitor it's cropped square,
but it's
stretched here.
But I like to crop out the dead space.
When I took this picture here, there's boring
sky on the
top, boring stuff on the bottom.
Why include that in
the scene?
I'm very big on cropping.
There are some
photographers who say forget it.
You have to get it
right in camera.
What I say -- you're shaking your
head.
I say to my publishers -- although I'm not
doing
any more books anymore I'm only doing apps,
and E-books,
and PDFs and things like that -- I used to
tell my
publishers, in a nice way, I used to say crop
my
pictures and you're a dead man [chuckles]
because I don't want
people to crop -- you know, you spend so much
time.
This is your art.
Never underestimate the importance of
cropping out that stuff.
So taking pictures in
Antarctica is not really that hard.
You know, it's so
beautiful, you have so many different subjects,
it's
overcast a lot of the times so you don't have
that high
contrast to deal with.
What's hard about shooting in
Antarctica is A, getting there, it takes two
days to get
there; and B, putting on the Wellington boots,
putting
on the long underwear, putting on the waterproof
pants,
putting on the waterproof jacket, putting
on the life
jacket, bringing gloves that let you operate
your
camera.
This is the hard part of shooting in
Antarctica.
It's not really finding the subjects or
doing the -- manipulating the controls.
What's really
interesting is what I was down in Antarctica,
there was
scientists from Wildlife Conservation International,
National Geographic, the Smithsonian, and
they're
studying the ice.
If you look at this ice formation
over there, they're trying to figure out why
the ice is
starting to look like penguins.
They just can't figure
it out.
So anyway, this is one of my favorite pictures
taken on the first trip.
Here's the cropped version of
it.
If you have a web site, I tell people -- oh,
this
is what I forgot to say.
Susan knows this.
If
someone's cell phone goes off during a presentation,
I
always make this -- you know what?
I have to put a
slide in.
I always make them come up here and do the
twist for 60 seconds, but I forgot to say
it.
[laughter] I forgot
to say it so it's okay.
Anyway, look how nice this
picture looks dressed up with a little bit
of drop
shadow, with a frame around it.
First impressions when
you do a web site are very, very important.
Put your
best work out there, ask your friends, you
know, to help
you select your best picture, your best design,
stuff
like that.
Anyway, I did go to photograph the animals,
I love the blue ice, they have these beautiful
Gentoo
penguins down there.
When I travel, I take basically
two lenses.
I have a two bodies, a Canon 7D and a Canon
5D Mark II.
On the 7D, which is a crop sensor image
camera, I have a telephoto zoom, either a
100 to
400-millimeter zoom or a 70 to 200, depending
upon how
far away the animals are.
In Antarctica, the animals
aren't hunted to you can get as close as this,
or even
closer.
You could touch them in Antarctica.
So I have
the telephoto lens on the crop sensor camera
because
animals are far away that crop sensor doesn't
really
bring you closer, but it's like you're getting
closer.
And on the full frame image sensor camera
what I have is
a wide angle zoom, usually a 17 to 40-millimeter
zoom,
maybe a 24 to 105-millimeter zoom, and I always
have a
fish eye with me, too.
I don't carry a lot of lenses,
as Susan will tell you.
I don't have a lot of lenses --
actually, I don't have a lot of lenses so
I don't carry
a lot of lenses.
You don't need, you know, a ton of
lenses.
I lead workshops where people show up and
they
have those belts, you know, and they have
like eight
lenses here, they have their backpacks with
nine more
lenses here, and they miss all the shots.
I like to
have my cameras handy over one shoulder, if
I have the
wide angle lens -- wide angle lens -- wide
angle zoom on
my camera body and on the other -- the telephoto.
Anyway, this was taken with the 100 to 400-millimeter
zoom and the background was very distracting
so I'm
shooting at a wide aperture.
I'm shooting at a wide
aperture to blur the background.
In wildlife
photography and in people photography, I do
the same
thing when I find a subject.
I take what's called the
environmental shot -- these are nesting albatrosses
on
Diego Ramirez Island -- I like to take what's
called the
environmental shot.
The subject in the environment, and
then I like to go in and take the closeup
so I'm telling
the story.
I don't know what shot I'm going to like
best later, I don't know which one someone
may buy, but
if you do it both ways, again, and having
those two
cameras lets you shoot fast, you'll have what
you need.
So when you shoot a subject with a lot of
white in it,
this is going to sound backwards, too.
Yes.
[Asking
question in the background]
>>RICK: Why did I chop the legs?
It looks like
I chopped the legs, but he's actually -- she
is actually
sitting on a nest.
So these are nesting albatrosses.
Okay?
So they have their nests in these little mud
--
mud piles here, so from back there it may
look like
that, but they're actually sitting on the
nest but you
have a good eye.
So anyway, if there's a lot of white
in the picture, like here, you want to -- if
you're
shooting on automatic, you want to set your
camera on
plus one as a starting point.
But, this may sound
backward.
You know you know, hey, there's all this
light.
It's so bright.
I want to set my camera on plus
one?
Well, you do.
Because all that light, all that
bright area, fools the camera's exposure meter
into
thinking the scene is brighter than it actually
is and
will underexpose your picture.
I shoot all my pictures,
except my flash pictures -- as you'll see
in the studio
later when we move over there with Cliff -- I
shoot
either on the aperture priority mode or the
shutter
priority mode.
A lot of my professional photographer
friends shoot on the aperture priority mode
or the
shutter priority mode.
If you think about it, there's
only one right exposure; right?
And if you use manual
or aperture priority, or shutter priority,
it doesn't
matter.
I found since I've been shooting a long time
that I can just use the exposure compensation
wheel on
my camera to dial in the right exposure very
quickly.
And in a case like this, a case like this,
a case like
this, case like this, the depth of field is
the most
important thing.
So why not shoot on the aperture
priority mode?
Set your aperture and then as the light
level changes, the camera will automatically
pick the
correct shutter speed for the existing situation.
Yes?
>> Male #1: What metering mode do you use?
>>RICK: What metering mode do I use?
I use the
evaluative metering mode and here's why because
I can
look at a scene like this and say okay, I'm
just going
to set this at evaluative metering.
If I just left it
on zero exposure compensation setting these
birds would
be a little washed out.
They look a little washed out
here, they're fine on the screen here.
Okay?
So
knowing that, that all this dark area would
fool the
camera's meter into thinking the scene has
all this dark
in it and no white, I have to underexpose
a little in
camera.
So I'm setting my exposure compensation for
a
scene like this a little under, make a third
under.
The
key in all photography is learning how to
see the light.
If you learn how to seen the light, then you
know how
you can make adjustments on your camera, knowing
again
that there's only white -- one right exposure
for you.
So in seeing the light, it's all about this.
It's first
seeing the contrast range in the scene.
There's not a
lot of contrast in the scene, so here we don't
have to
make that many adjustments exposure wise.
Right?
So we
have to learn to see the contrast range in
the scene; we
have to learn to see the direction of light;
we have to
learn how to see the quality of light, hard
or soft,
it's soft; and then we have to learn -- what's
the other
thing about light?
Color.
So we have to learn how to
see the contrast range in the scene, the quality
of
light, the direction of light, and the color
of light.
Once we learn how to the light, then we can
make the
right adjustments with the -- inside our camera,
or add
a flash, use a reflector or diffuser, wait
for a
different time of day,, and then after we
do that on
site, then we can go into the digital darkroom
and work
and play with the light.
If you think about it, every
picture I'm going to show you right here has
exactly the
same main element, and that's light.
So it's very, very
important to learn how to see the light, then
learn how
to control the light, and we'll be talking
about that
more a little in the presentation.
One of my
photography tips -- one of my famous one-liners
is
"The name of the game is to fill the frame."
I like to
shoot tight.
I like -- like here, I like to fill the
frame with the subject, yet there is something
to be
said for negative space, for dead space.
So when I give
you these tips, try them and try actually
the total
opposite of them.
But most -- we were talking about
this before when we sat down.
When you're photographing
a person, when you think you're close, get
closer; when
you're photographing an animal, a building,
when you
think you're close, get closer.
And cropping doesn't
bring you closer, but it emphasizes the subject
a lot --
a lot more.
This is a very basic tip, but I shoot
everything vertically, I shoot everything
horizontally.
Again,on what I'm going to like, I don't know
what
someone else is going to like who might want
to buy the
picture.
If I'm going to offer the picture to a
magazine, I don't know whether they have space
for a
horizontal or a vertical.
Again, a very basic tip, but
I do that.
Again, here are some monochromatic images.
If the pictures don't have a lot of color,
I'm going to
make them black and white.
And when I go somewhere, I'm
trying to tell the story.
I'm thinking as a magazine
photographer; I'm thinking if I'm putting
a slide show
together.
So this would make a nice ending picture for
a slide show.
Try to tell the story, just don't go to
Antarctica or wherever and say okay, I'm going
to take a
lot of closeup pictures of this or that.
Try to tell
the story of wherever you go.
So the first trip was
amazing.
I had an unbelievable time.
The people liked
me teaching so they said hey, could you come
back?
So
two years ago they asked me to come back.
Now this --
this was a special trip to photograph the
emperor
penguins.
People save up their whole lives.
On their
life list they want to photograph the emperor
penguins.
The penguins are about this high, they're
in remote
colonies, but they are magnificent, magnificent
animals
so they needed a pro.
So I said "Sure, I'll go."
So the company hired me,
but this is a very short trip.
It was a 12-day trip -- not
counting getting there, okay, which is like
a day, and
coming It's three days going over the Drake's
Passage, which
can be the roughest seas in the world, right,
three days
returning, only six days of shooting.
So this is a big
investment for just six days of shooting.
Again, this
is a lifelong dream for people.
So we leave Ushuaia,
the sky is great, it was sunny, people are
cheering,
we're having champagne on the bow of the boat,
the
stern, all the way around the rail.
It was amazing
going there.
So we're getting closer to Antarctica,
we're getting closer to this emperor penguin
colony.
This is called pancake ice.
We start seeing this.
We
see our first tiny little penguin, you can
see him up
here.
People are cheering hey, we're getting closer
to
the colony.
Now, this was really like a National
Geographic expedition.
We're in this Russian ice
breaker and it's going through the ice, the
ice is,
like, smashing off the bow at night when we
were
sleeping.
It was so noisy that you really felt that
you
were on an expedition.
One of my photography tips in
addition to the name of the game is to fill
the frame is
to always look back.
Everyone's on the bow, here's the
bow crashing through the ice, but I like to
look back.
Always look up, always look down, always look
back;
This'll open up a whole new world of photo
opportunities
for you.
So here I look back and I see the path that
this ice breaker is just breaking through
the ice.
So
we get to Antarctica, the ice is so thick
now the boat
is moving really slow, again, the ice is crashing
all
around.
The night before -- after three days of
traveling, all right, we get to Antarctica
the night
before they bring out these two Russian-made
helicopters.
Russian ice breaker, Russian helicopters.
How cool is this if you want to talk about
being on an
expedition?
So they bring them out to test them --
they're bringing them out to test them because
we're
going to fly over to the emperor penguin colony
because
the ship can't get close.
So they bring them out and it
starts to get overcast.
Now, although there is no such
thing as a bad day for pictures, everyone,
you know,
they wanted that bright sunlight, they wanted
the blue
sky, the penguins against the blue sky, and
also it was
a lot warmer when the sun comes out.
So the captain
says -- he gets on the PA system and he says,
I don't
know if we're going to be able to go tomorrow
after
three days on the ship, after one day of trying
to get
there.
So we go in, have dinner, we come out after
dinner, and the sun comes out.
So everyone's like
really happy and saying I can't believe it.
This is
going to be great.
We go back inside and I'm teaching
photography, I'm teaching Photoshop, light
room,
teaching all this stuff, getting everyone's
cameras set
up.
We wake up the next morning, and this is what
it
looked like.
It was totally overcast.
Captain gets on
the PA and says, sorry, we're not going anywhere.
So
this is day one.
Well, on day two to four it snowed.
[Laughing]
>>RICK: So we couldn't.
So we're stuck on the
ship and this was, again, a lifelong dream
for people.
But it got worse.
Half the ship, including me, got
what's called the Norwalk virus, and the Norwalk
virus
is -- he's laughing so I guess you know what
it is.
It's the most -- it's like the worst virus
you
could possibly get.
You feel like you're going to die.
I was calling Susan on the ship's phone, I
was telling
her where the will is and stuff like this
because I
really thought I was gonna die.
It's so bad.
So
this is day two to four.
So on day five I figured I
have to get off this ship.
I just have to get off this
ship so I'm taking some snapshots just walking
around
the ship.
And by the way, as the pro, they don't give
you -- they don't give you the best cabin.
My cabin was
way up on the top left there.
They give the crew the
top cabins so when the boat swings like this,
you know,
we get the severest cases of being seasick.
So anyway,
on day six, the last day, there was a mutiny.
The
guests -- we got together actually in a theater
like
this, and the guests said, we paid all this
money; we
want to go.
So the captain said okay, if you want to
go, we'll go.
So we get over -- we get in the
helicopters, he's flying us over, but here's
the thing.
We couldn't land closer than 2 miles -- 2
miles to the
emperor penguin colony because they didn't
want to scare
the penguins with the helicopters.
So with all this
gear -- I have a 40-pound backpack -- Cliff,
you'll see
most of the gear that I have this afternoon
--
forty-pound backpack, I've been sick, the
guests have
been sick for all these days, we walk over
the ice with
our life jackets because you're on ice so
they set up
this camp there.
So we're getting closer to the emperor
penguin colony and it was really cool seeing
these
emperor penguins.
This is how big they are.
And the
thing is, they're not -- they're not hunted,
so you can
get very close to these animals just like
in Galapagos
you can get very close to the animals in Galapagos
because they're not hunted.
So this is one shot that I
took, kind of like this.
This is called "Babysitting",
right.
It's the adult -- it's the mama emperor penguin
with the chicks, and this is the other.
You've probably
seen pictures like this on National Geographic.
Beautiful blue sky, the parents, the chick,
the
background's out of focus, nice framing.
Well, this
isn't the original shot; this is the original
shot.
As
a travel photographer, if a photojournalist
was there,
he or she would publish this type of picture,
but
because I'm a travel photographer, I have
the license to
enhance my pictures.
So what I did is I just added the
gradual filter and increased the contrast
and
saturation.
But if there's ever a magazine published
called National Adventure and they want an
article
Rick's Trip from Hell believe me -- believe
me, I am
ready to write this article.
And the article would
actually be called this: "The Safety of Reminiscence."
Marco Polo had a wonderful saying and the
saying is "An
adventure is misery and discomfort... relived
in the
safety of reminiscence."
like here we're laughing about
this, I'm having a good time, I hope you're
having a
good time, right?
But again I felt like I was going to
die.
On a more serious note, the most important
thing
that we can do in our photography, I think,
is buy a
camera -- no.
[chuckles] The most important thing that we
can do I
think is set a goal.
Setting goals is so important.
I
used to tell my son -- Susan and I would tell
my son
this all the time.
He set the goal to be the
valedictorian in high school; he achieved
that goal.
You guys are working at Google here.
You set the goal
to get a job at Google; obviously it worked.
In
photography -- in life and in photography
we must set
goals.
I was teaching a workshop up in Alaska
photographing bald eagles and I was on the
back of a
boat -- and actually it's a funny story.
I was in the
back of a boat hand-holding my Canon with
a 70 to 200
millimeter F4 lens, which is less expensive
than the 70
to 200 2A lens.
I'm hand holding this and there's guys
on the back of the boat with $11,000 400-millimeter
setups with the 400-millimeter 2A lens and
the super
body and all this stuff, and I'm hand holding
shots.
You don't need the world's best gear to get
pretty nice
shots.
If the lights were a little darker, you'd
see
that this picture really pops.
But anyway, we're on the
back of the boat and guys are shooting the
eagles coming
down, shooting the eagles coming up, catching
the fish,
and I have all these pictures here, but one
morning I
set the goal to get the shot.
This is the one shot I
really wanted to get.
I wanted to get a symmetrical
shot of the eagle coming in to catch a fish
with the
perfect reflection here.
So I set that goal.
So what
did I have to do?
I knew I had to use a fast shutter
speed, I knew I had to set my exposure -- underexposure
just -- underexposing just a little so the
white
feathers weren't all overexposed.
This is actually the
hardest subject I've ever photographed because
the
animal's moving fast and you have really dark
feathers
and dark background against really bright
here.
So anyway, I had to use rapid frame advance;
set
the exposure right; use AI servo focus, which
is like
focus tracking, it tracks the subject; and
I had to
focus on a specific area.
And we actually had the
captain move to boat to an area where we had
beautiful
reflections.
We set the goal, I got the shot.
So in
your photography it's very, very important
to set a
specific goals.
If you go up to Alaska on a trip, it's
not a goal I'm going to get great shots of
bald eagles.
I'm going to get a shot of the eagle with
the talons
coming out.
I'm going to get the shot of an eagle, in
one second, of just catching the fish.
I'm going to get
a shot of the eagle taking off after it just
caught a
fish.
I'm going to get a nice action shot like this.
I'm going to shoot up.
I'm going to shoot down.
I'm
going to shoot all around.
If you make like a hit list,
again, set that goal.
You'll know where you're going.
Yes?
>> Female #2: So when you were photos of the
eagle, were you
focusing on the white part on the eagle's
head or the
darkest--
>>RICK: I was focusing on the body because
it's
a very small point.
So I'm actually using the center
focus point on my camera even though my camera
has 45
autofocus points -- you know, these cameras
today have
all these different focus points -- I'm using
that AI
servo focus and I want to focus right -- like
here, like
right on the animal's body.
But talking about animal --
these shots, if you look at all these shots
they have
something in common.
When I'm photographing animals and
people in most cases if the eye is not in
focus, if the
eye's not well lit, I feel I've missed the
shot.
That's
what I strive for.
The reason I say most people
photography, if Marlon Brando was here and
he said hey,
Marlon Brando -- it's really fun to be at
Google -- --
he'd say well, Rick, most of the times that's
true.
But
you might remember when I shot the Godfather
I used top
lighting.
I used top lighting so the people looking
at
the movie couldn't see into the subject's
eyes because I
wanted to create a sense of mystery.
I'm sure,
Katherine, you like the eyes most of the time.
It's
very important in portraiture and wedding
photographer -- wedding photography to light
the eyes;
right?
Okay.
So anyway, that's the thing in wildlife
photography.
So what do we do?
We're actually
positioning the boat so we have good light
on the
animals' eyes.
I was talking -- I was giving a talk
down at the California Photo Fest last week
and it was
on composition.
How many people here have heard the
composition technique the Rule of Thirds?
Okay.
Just
about everybody.
How many people have heard the
composition technique Rule of Odds?
Nobody.
The Rule
of Odds is actually a very good composition
technique.
You put odd things in a picture, they're going
to stand
out.
You put, you know, even things, they don't
stand
out as much for whatever reason.
So this has three
dolphins in here -- actually whales before
rather
than -- and then four.
So I had a lot of pictures with
four in them, but I liked the shot with the
three.
I
was thinking about that composition technique,
the Rule
of Odds.
Simplicity is really important, too so right
here we have just one animal.
Now, I have these
beautiful patterns here.
I'm using that polarizing
filter that we were talking about before to
cut through
the glare on the water.
If you're shooting in water,
around water, over water, next to water, you
want to
bring a polarizing filter.
Yes?
>> Female #3: Do you like a circular polarizer
or do you just
like the sheet for a polarizer?
>> RICK: Well, the circular -- we used to
have
what's called the linear polarizing filter
before you
probably got into photography.
Now they had to develop
what's called circular polarizing filters
for the
autofocus cameras; the linear polarizing filters
didn't
work.
But I -- that's what I use.
I like to use the
circular polarizing filters.
And again telling the
story.
I'm trying to tell the whole story of the
whale
so I'm doing the whale's tail.
This picture might look
a little confusing, but what's going on here
is I was
pretty lucky.
These whales come up and they were eating
the krill.
The reason it looks kind of weird is because
the jaws come -- they distend and they like
open like
this to the side so they can get the maximum
amount of
krill.
It's pretty cool.
Again, telling the story, watching the background.
You know, if I took -- this picture could
have been
taken off Long Island not too far from my
house.
This
picture looks like it was taken in Alaska.
We want to
take pictures that have what's called a sense
of place.
This picture's nice, this picture's nice;
the closeups,
they're nice, but they could have been taken
anywhere.
. So think about that when you're taking pictures.
Think
about how can I take a picture that has a
sense of
place?
Another tip I want to share with you I learned
from my friend Dr. Dick Zakia, he where to
wonderful
book called "Perception and Imaging".
"Perception and
Imaging", Dr. Dick Zakia.
In that book he has nothing
about F-stops and shutter speeds.
It's all about -- or
raw, or JPEGs, or image sensors, or anything
like that.
It's all about -- what he talks about -- what
he talks
about is why we like pictures, the perception,
and how
it relates to imaging.
But one of his best tips is use
your camera like a spaceship.
I teach a lot of
workshops.
We were doing a workshop last week down at
the pier, the pier in San Luis Obispo actually,
I
forget, in Cayucos, not too far from San Luis
Obispo.
Everyone shows up with their tripods and their
cameras
are like this at eye level.
When you start using your
camera like a spaceship, you could come up
with all new different
composition techniques.
Here I'm on the back of the
boat, I'm holding my camera probably about
6 inches
above the water with the [chuckles] strap
on to make sure I didn't
lose it.
But I wanted to have this feeling of speed
that our boat is like cruising up through
the water up
in Alaska.
If I was up like this, it wouldn't have the
same effect.
So use your camera like a spaceship; tilt
it up; tilt it down; tilt it to the left;
tilt it to the
right.
If you think about that spaceship technique,
you'll see that you that you will come up
with different
pictures.
As far as the composition technique, another
one, leading lines.
Here we have these leading lines or
leading shapes that are leading the viewer
right up to
this mountain in the back.
There are a million
different composition techniques.
I only have time
really to share a few with you with you, but
contours,
contours are another form of composition.
This is just
a closeup of this.
Basically I'm doing the same thing I
did with the pictures of the nesting albatrosses
in
Antarctica.
I'm shooting wide and I'm shooting close,
and if I do this, I have enough pictures to
illustrate
all these different composition techniques.
And here's
one more.
I'm photographing this glacier, this
beautiful glacier up in Alaska.
Fish eye lens,
15-millimeter lens, one of the widest lens
you could
buy, and then I'm using my 100 to 400 to capture
this,
to tell the -- to show the details.
Details help to
tell the story.
We can tell the whole story -- not the
whole story.
We could tell a broader story by using
this wide angle shot here and then a closer
shot.
And
speaking of details, here's a nice shot of
an iceberg.
Kind of boring, but look what happens when
we move in
for a closeup.
This is taken with a 100 to
400-millimeter lens.
I'm looking for patterns.
Patterns are yet another composition technique.
This is
an HDR shot.
You guys into HDR?
Anyone here into HDR?
Just one?
Two?
Three, four, five.
HDR is where it's
at, our eyes, speaking about -- yes, right?
[audience member replies] Our eyes
have a dynamic range of about 11 F-stops.
The best
digital camera on the planet has a dynamic
range that
can see five F-stops.
So with HDR we can get back to
that 11 F-stop range and even go beyond it.
So what's
going to happen is we can create images, you
know, so
this scene looks, you know, in our image like
it looks
to our eyes.
Here we can see deep, deep into the
shadows here, yet the ice and the clouds outside
-- ice
and the clouds outside are not overexposed.
I'm going
to jump out of this show for just one second.
Yeah.
>>
[Male asking question in the background]
>> RICK: Well, actually I have it here.
I don't
have to jump out.
How do I compare HDR to the zone
system?
Well, the zone system was developed by -- did
you ask -- was developed by Ansel Adams.
>> Male #2: Yeah, I know it.
>> RICK: Right.
And for those of you who
didn't -- don't know -- and what Ansel Adams
-- if you
want to have fun, do a Google search.
Right now you
could some have fun.
Tell me how many pages come up "I
hate HDR."
You're going to find 50,000 -- maybe not.
>> Male #3: 2.1 million.
>> RICK: 2.1 million?
>> Male #3: Only
>> RICK: Only?
>> Male #3: In .30 seconds.
[laughter]
>> RICK: Okay.
So that's how good Google is.
But anyway, I love HDR.
Ansel Adams, he used the zone
system to find out what the different exposures
were in
these different zones from very dark to very
light, and
he created HDR images using burning, and dodging,
different papers, different chemicals, different
exposure times, then he would dry his pictures
in the
microwave oven, as you may know.
But what HDR does is
it -- what these programs let us do today
is a matter of
minutes.
So here's a good example of HDR for you guys
who are not -- who are not into HDR.
Okay.
So this is
an HDR image, high, high dynamic range image.
Here is the original
shot.
Here is the middle exposure for HDR in this
case
I had to take five exposures from the dark
-- that I
captured from the darkest area to the brightest
area, I
had to take those five exposures and then
process them.
Actually, here I used HDR Efex Pro, by
Nik Software.
You can do a search on this.
Actually,
if you go on my site, RickSammon.Info you
can get a
15 percent discount on it.
But anyway, without HDR this
is what the scene would look like; it looks
terrible.
With HDR, this is what the scene looks like.
It's kind
of magical.
But the key is, the key is you have to
take -- you have to take enough exposures,
again, to
capture that dynamic range.
So anyway, on my site,
RickSammon.info if you go to save on creative
plugins,
you'll see a bunch of tutorials on this.
Let's see how
fast you can find this.
Go on RickSammon.info
>> Male #4: RickSammon.Info?
>>RICK: .info.
>> Male #4: Oh.
Okay.
>>RICK: And then type in the search window
"HDR
must-know info".
So if you go in this -- Yeah.
HDR
must-know info.
So if you want a nice little --
actually, it's a long tutorial on HDR, you'll
find that.
It's probably about a thousand words, about
eight or 12
different examples of HDR but HDR really is
amazing.
Yes?
>> [Male asking question in the background]
>>RICK: Okay.
This is a very good question.
So he's saying I'm up here talking about like
I know
what I'm talking about; right?
[chuckles] But how about the person
who wants to learn about light?
Okay.
Well, I don't
have a picture of a histogram up here now,
but does
anyone not know what a histogram is?
Okay.
So on the
back of your camera, you have a histogram.
What that
histogram is telling you, is it's telling
you about the
bright areas and the dark areas.
If you have a lot of
dark areas in your picture, you can look at
each -- like
you mentioned the zone system.
You can look at your
histogram like you have a pile of bricks over
here, and
if you have a picture like this with some
dark areas
going to have bricks piled up like this way
on this side
of your histogram for the dark areas.
For the
highlights over here, you're going to have
bricks piled
up like this.
If you have a picture just taken on an
overcast day without a lot of highlights or
shadows,
you're just going to have what looks like
an even
mountain range, like this.
When I talk about light, I do talk
about what I said before, that we have to
learn how to
see the light, the contrast range in the scene,
the
direction of light, the color of light, the
quality of
light, but the histogram is your light meter,
so this is
actually a very, very important thing.
I don't use a
light meter.
A couple of my friends still use light
meters, but -- you don't use a light meter,
right?
You
use a histogram.
>>Male #5: Or a spot meter.
>> RICK: Or a spot meter in your camera.
The
histogram what you want to do is when you're
shooting,
you want to move your histogram over to the
right.
If
you do a search on this, move the histogram
to the
right, let's see how many pages you get on
that, this is
the key because in your -- if this is your
histogram
here, most of the information -- more than
half of your
information is captured over here.
If you have a
histogram with nothing over here when you
try to pull
stuff out of the shadows over here, it's going
to be
very noisy.
This is why the basic tip -- how many
pages?
>> Male: #6: 2.2 million.
>> RICK: 2.2 million.
Pretty soon you're not
going to need speakers at Google anymore,
just do
searches move to histogram to the right.
So anyway, you
want to move the histogram to the right.
You don't want
that spike.
If that spike is right to the edge here,
you're going to lose detail.
This is the most important
thing -- I think I have to stand over here
for the mic.
This is the most important thing I talk about
when
people ask me questions like when you talk
about light,
what's the most important thing?
Expose for the
highlights.
You want to expose for the highlights.
Look at this scene.
What's the brightest part of the
scene?
Might be the reflection on the water right
here.
Here we have detail here, it's a little washed
out
because the lights are on but that's okay
because we're
all here to learn.
But I'm always exposing for the
highlights.
Did you ever shoot slides?
>> Male #7: Oh, yeah.
>> RICK: Oh, yeah.
when you shot slides, Katherine?
She used to shoot
slides.
Your exposure had to be right on, dead on,
because if they were over, they were gone.
Now, with
digital, if your highlights are overexposed
by more than
a stop, you can get them back, I mean, under
-- just
about a stop.
If they're over more than a stop, you're not
going
to get them back.
So it's very important to expose for
the highlights and move your histogram to
the right.
As
far as people photography goes, and travel
photography,
I always like to put a person in the scene.
This
picture taken out in Laos early one morning,
I love the
clouds, I love the setting, but if we take
the person
out of the scene -- this is taken a few minutes
before -- it doesn't have, you know, the same
kind of
feeling.
Now, some people here -- Ansel Adams probably
would like the scene because he didn't include
people
in the scene, but I like to put people in
the scene.
Both are valid.
It's up to you and shoot it -- shoot it
both ways.
When we were talking before someone said
they wanted to do people photography.
Who said -- right.
So here's an example.
Let me see where this other shot
is here.
Might be -- yeah.
Okay.
When you're
photographing a person, my No. 1 thing is
this, to think
about this: The closer you are to the -- I
don't want
to get too far away from the podium -- The
closer you
are to the person, the more intimate the picture
becomes.
So when you think you're close, get closer.
This is over in Laos.
We were there last year.
Kind of
a boring shot, but it's kind of cool.
The monks get out
early in the morning and they walk down the
road
barefoot, and they get the alms from these
people giving
them rice, and candy, and stuff like that.
But it looks
like a snapshot.
If you just get a little closer, you
feel more intimate; you feel like you're more
part of
the scene.
So again shooting close gives a picture a
greater sense of intimacy.
When you think you're close,
get closer.
But something else is going on there.
I
used a slow shutter speed to add a sense of
movement to
the picture.
Here, these guys, the monks could have
been standing still.
And actually here they were kind
of standing still, but you want to add a sense
of motion
to your pictures.
This is one of the things we have to
do as photographers.
We're shooting stills -- we're
shooting stills, but we want to add a sense
of motion to
our pictures.
So play around with shutter speeds, play
around with aperture.
So anyway, Laos is an incredible
place, northern Thailand is an incredible
place.
This
is one of the temples, an HDR shot.
Without HDR, you
wouldn't be able to see these beautiful paintings
on the
background.
And it's -- you know, traveling's such a
great education.
You learn so much.
Here's the inside
of the temple.
You can see all these beautiful
paintings over here.
So some of the paintings depict a
scene like this, if you're good in life, the
afterlife
will be nice.
Okay.
Here's another scene, again, if
you're good in life, when you die everything
will be
nice.
Well, if you're not good, they show this is
what
happens.
This is what happens if you drink too much,
okay, and then you die, this is what happens
to you.
All right, this is if you're a murderer what
happens to
you.
So again, traveling is a great education.
So they
bring the kids to this temple -- these temples
to show
them hey, this is what can happen.
But if you want a
great place to go, I've been a lot of places,
I've
said this before, more than a hundred countries,
Laos is
like Thailand was like 50 years ago.
It's still very
remote.
We went on this beautiful river ride here.
This is a daylight fill-in flash picture here.
I think
I told you the only time I use a flash in
the manual
exposure mode is if I'm taking a flash -- or
a flash
shot.
All my other pictures are on either aperture
priority or shutter priority.
But it's so remote there,
people are still fishing with nets.
I like this shot
because it's balanced.
When you're taking a picture,
another thing that you want to think about,
yet another
thing you want to think about is balance.
So the net
here falling on the water, and the fisherman,
it has
some action, but it's balanced.
Think about how you can
balance your pictures.
Now, these aren't the fish he
caught, but one of the things that's really
fun to do in
remote countries like Laos, Thailand, Cambodia,
some
places in Central America, is like to go to
the markets.
Here this man was preparing our lunch.
Katherine, is
this the kind of lunch we're going to have
tomorrow,
Katherine, before the photo?
>> Katherine: I hope not.
>>RICK: You hope not?
Anyway, you see, you
learn what's going on in different cultures.
You know,
we have so much here, we really do have so
much here and
what we have to do to survive is a lot different
from
when a lot of other people around the country
-- around
the world have to survive.
And one more thing on
traveling is such a great education, this
is just a
snapshot, but I took this shot and the next
few shots
because they're these unexploded fuel tanks
here as
decorations around the village.
You see it here, you
see it here, and you see it in this shot.
Again, these
are just snapshots, but again getting back
to this
education thing, during the Vietnam War when
the pilots
would go up, you know, on their bombing raids
and they
couldn't land with full fuel tanks, right?
They had to
get rid of them otherwise their planes could
explode if
they didn't land correctly.
They just dropped these
tanks like over beautiful villages like you've
just seen
before.
So you learn this stuff.
This is part of being
a travel photographer.
Getting back to that shooting
horizontally and vertically.
This is Angkor Wat in
Cambodia.
Nice enough shot, right, shooting
horizontally, but here's a vertical shot,
an HDR shot.
We can see the white clouds aren't overexposed
and
washed out, yet we can see into the shadows.
Now, one
thing on HDR is this: We can open up all the
shadows,
right?
But when we open up all the shadows our pictures
look flat.
I want you to remember this when it comes
to
shadows.
Shadows can be your friend; shadows add a
sense of depth and dimension to a picture;
and my friend
Frank Doorhof has this expression, "Shadows
are the soul
of the picture."
So, you know, just because we can open
up the shadows, it doesn't mean that we have
to open up
the shadows.
Another thing we have to do is add a sense
of depth and dimension to our pictures.
We see the
world in three dimensions: Height, width,
and depth;
our cameras only see two.
Here this is a side of one of
the temples in Angkor Wat Cambodia.
Here's another side
of one of the temples.
If you shoot at an angle, you
can shoot sense of depth.
If I'm going to photograph
this room right now here at Google, it looks
very flat
shooting straight on like that; if I go over
here, it's
going to have a much greater sense of depth.
So try to
create a sense of depth and dimension in our
pictures.
So it's almost 4:00 o'clock and I think we're
going to
start our studio session kind of soon after
that.
Let me see if I have anything else I can show
you
quickly here before we take any -- well, I'll
tell you
this.
How many people were at my presentation last
time?
Okay.
Two.
So I'm just going to end with this
quick little story.
So I teach a lot of workshops
around the world.
This is a workshop in Botswana, one
of my favorite shots.
This picture illustrates a lot of
points in photography.
One, the name of the game is to
fill the frame; Number 2, light the eyes;
Number 3, have a
plain background; Number 4, use a wide aperture
to blur the
background if it's distracting; and getting
back to my
friend's -- my new friend in the front's comment
about
light, I'm looking to expose for the highlights,
the
brightest part of the scene first, which is
right here.
I don't want that overexposed and washed out.
So
this -- and you want a little bit of expression
on the
animal's eyes; he's looking for something.
So this
picture illustrates a lot of different -- a
lot of
different techniques.
Here we see -- excuse me -- what
simple cropping can do.
I not only cropped this
picture; I increased the saturation.
How many people
sharpen their pictures here?
Okay.
The key to
sharpening the picture is using selective
sharpening.
Rarely do you want to sharpen the entire picture.
You
want to sharpen just the most important part
of the
picture.
So here I'm sharpening the animal's face.
I'm
sharpening the body, but not as much as the
face.
There'd be no reason to sharpen around this
animal
because I want the attention to go to the
animal, plus,
if you sharpen the dark out-of-focus areas,
that
increases the noise.
Always sharpen selectively, unless
you're taking a picture of a rose, then you
want the
whole thing very sharp.
But also I use a technique like
Ansel Adams used.
Ansel Adams had a great expression.
He said, "A picture's not done until I darken
the
edges."
Renaissance painters did the same thing, they
darkened the edges.
So I darken the edges to draw more
attention to the -- to the main subject.
If you go on
safari, having a good guide is the key.
We're driving
around in the jeep -- or the Land Rover, and
the guide
says, "Man, look at that lion.
I can't believe that,"
and he's pointing to the lion.
Well, we can't see it.
This is why you want to go on safari because
if you look closely, you'll see that -- with
a good
guide, you'll see that there's a lion hiding
in the
shadows right there.
One thing, by the way, if you're
into photographing birds around here, or owls,
or any
kind of wildlife around here, if you want
a better
chance of finding the animals rather than
looking left
to right, like most of us read, search the
scene from
right to left.
It slows you down and it's really a much
better way to find the animals.
You'll see if you're
outside searching for a subject if you move
like this,
you're going to go faster than going like
that because
you're used to going like this when you are
-- when you
are reading.
Okay.
So I'm just going to end with these
couple of pictures.
On safari with this guy, we're in
this little plane, a light plane, we're landing
on this
runway, the guides on the bottom on the runway
are
shooing the animals off the runway, the elephants
off
the runway.
So we come down on the runway and the guide
whips open the door and says "Quick, quick.
These lions
are mating.
You have to come.
You have to see this."
So because I'm ready, like I told you I was,
with my wide
angle lens on one shoulder, my telephoto lens
--
telephoto zoom on the other, I'm in the jeep
in one
second, the land rover in one second.
This guy's
fumbling around getting his stuff out of the
bag.
I
said, I can't believe we're might miss this
thing.
The guide's saying, "Hurry up!
This doesn't happen too
often.
Lot a lot of people get to see this."
So here's
the male lion.
He really wanted to mate.
Here's the
female -- this goes on for three days -- she
didn't want
to mate any longer, okay?
But I really wanted to get a
shot.
I wanted to get this shot.
I call this the Love
Bite.
Here's the female biting the lion trying to
keep
him away.
Here I used a 500th of a second shutter speed
to freeze the action, but here's the story.
You see
these twigs here?
Well, there were some twigs right in
front of this scene right here.
Well, before we got in
the vehicle the guide says to me, he says,
"Whatever you
do, don't stand up.
Don't move in the vehicle."
Again,
this is been going on for three days; the
animals
haven't eaten; who knows.
You don't want to distract
the animals.
Well, I forgot what he said and I was so
interested in getting this shot I stood up.
As I stood
up, the lions stopped what they were doing
and they
started coming toward the vehicle.
So you've seen this
on National Geographic where the lion's crouched
down
like this, and they're going through the grass
and
they're coming closer and closer and closer.
And as the
guy's -- the guy's saying to me as they get
closer,
first he said, "Don't move," then he said,
"Don't move,"
then he said, "Don't move," then he's just
going, "Don't
move," like this, because they're coming closer,
and
closer, and closer, and closer.
Anyway, they come right
up like as close as you two guys are right
here.
They
look up, and this is what happens.
Though they didn't
jump up and kill me, they were so hot and
tired they
were just looking for some shade.
They lied down in the
shade of the vehicle.
[Laughing]
>>RICK: So listen, I want to thank you all
very
much for joining me here at Google.
I hope you learned
a lot; I hope you had a lot of fun.
Everyone who comes
to my seminars or workshops is a student for
life so if
you want to send me questions, it's just Rick
-- well,
actually, my Google address is
RickGodfatherSammon@google.
Trey Ratcliff, who actually
introduced me to Cliff and my friends here
at Google
gave me that title Godfather because when
I met him he
says, "Man, Rick, you're one of the oldest
guys I know
that's still into photography."
[Laughing]
>> RICK: So anyway, and you can contact me
through my site RickSammon.info . So thank
-- yes?
>> Male #8: Do they allow that name on Google+?
>> RICK: Pardon?
Do they allow that name
Godfather?
Oh, I guess so.
I've had it for a few
months.
So thank you very much.
I hope you had a good
time and learned a lot.
[Clapping]